- [Instructor] We're told that triangle
A-prime, B-prime, C-prime,
so that's this red triangle over here,
is the image of triangle ABC,
so that's this blue triangle here,
under rotation about the origin,
so we're rotating about the origin here.
Determine the angle of rotation.
So like always, pause this video,
see if you can figure it out.
So I'm just gonna think about
how did each of these
points have to be rotated
to go from A to A-prime, or B to B-prime,
or from C to C-prime?
So let's just start with A.
So this is where A starts.
Remember we're rotating about the origin.
That's why I'm drawing this
line from the origin to A.
And where does it get rotated to?
Well, it gets rotated to right over here.
So the rotation is going in
the counterclockwise direction,
so it's going to have a positive angle.
So we can rule out these
two right over here.
And the key question is, is
this 30 degrees or 60 degrees?
And there's a bunch of ways
that you could think about it.
One, 60 degrees would
be 2/3 of a right angle,
while 30 degrees would
be 1/3 of a right angle.
A right angle would look
something like this.
So this looks much more
like 2/3 of a right angle,
so I'll go with 60 degrees.
Another way to think
about is that 60 degrees
is 1/3 of 180 degrees,
which this also looks
like right over here.
And if you do that with any of the points,
you would see a similar thing.
So just looking at A to
A-prime makes me feel good
that this was a 60-degree rotation.
Let's do another example.
So we are told quadrilateral
A-prime, B-prime, C-prime,
D-prime, in red here,
is the image of quadrilateral
ABCD, in blue here,
under rotation about point Q.
Determine the angle of rotation.
So once again, pause this video,
and see if you can figure it out.
Well, I'm gonna tackle this the same way.
I don't have a coordinate plane here,
but it's the same notion.
I can take some initial point
and then look at its image
and think about, well, how
much did I have to rotate it?
I could do B to B-prime,
although this might be
a little bit too close.
So I'm going from B to,
let me do a new color here,
just 'cause this color is
too close to, I'll use black,
so we're going from B to
B-prime right over here.
We are going clockwise,
so it's going to be a negative rotation.
So we can rule that and that out.
And it looks like a right angle.
This looks like a right angle,
so I feel good about
picking negative 90 degrees.
We could try another
point and feel good that
that also meets that negative 90 degrees.
Let's say D to D-prime.
So this is where D is initially.
This is where D is,
and this is where D-prime is.
And once again, we are moving clockwise,
so it's a negative rotation.
And this looks like a right angle,
definitely more like a right
angle than a 60-degree angle.
And so this would be negative 90 degrees,
definitely feel good about that.